he's a cop she's a crook together their
law and disorder
what is the comic filter comic filter is
a character's way of viewing reality
different from what reality really is a
strong Comic character has an
identifiable and consistent comic filter
strong in the sense that it's completely
uncompromising I think about everything
this way
uh
examples abound let's let's uh
here's here's one I teach from uh he's a
cop she's a crook together they're law
and disorder
his comic filter is
Law and Order he's a cop he wants to do
the right thing in all situations he's
going to do the right thing
her comic filter is break the rules
I'm going to do the wrong thing I'm a
free spirit I'm an Outlaw I'm a rebel
I'm an anarchist
the world is good when the rules are
broken so now you have one character
whose comic filter is obey the rules and
you have another character whose comic
filter is Break The Rules you put those
two characters together and give them
strong comic filters they're going to
fight forever over who gets to be right
and this is the heart and soul of a
sitcom this is how you build two-hander
sitcoms what they call comic opposites
in sitcom you take a comic filter
exaggerate it to the end and then pit it
against a similar an opposite comic
filter and have them go to war then if
you're looking for stories you can just
look at any situation and ask how will
this character filter this reality
through his or her comic filter the
example that I use now it's a little
outdated because it involves stolen
pirated DVDs which don't exist anymore
but let's just imagine that she brings
home a box of pirated DVDs but it's DVDs
that he really wants to see like it's
the hot new movies what a nice moral
dilemma for him because he knows he's
breaking the rules if he watches the
DVDs but he's
drawn he wants to he has inner conflict
I want to follow the rules but I want to
watch the DVD that's the story and
resolving that conflict is the end of
that story I don't know how it'll end I
have a feeling that he's going to end up
watching those DVDs but somehow disavow
them I wasn't breaking the rules
according to my own terms so that I can
still feel good about my comic filter
going forward right maybe she got them
at the swap meet and then he needs to
watch them so he can make sure that the
entire thing was pirated and then he's
going to go back and and and we'll
report to wherever wow I I I feel like
you and I could work effectively because
you you have this knack for taking an
idea and yes ending it to something
you're you're what if tool is working
quite well thank you and especially
because oh yeah I can see that what he's
doing on a psychological level is
creating a rationalization now it might
be my job in our creative partnership to
shine a light on what's Happening and
then your job to make it funny or the
other way around or maybe we change
roles but that's the way this
collaboration is working because I'm
saying it's funny because he's got these
DVDs and he has conflict and then you're
saying well based on that conflict he
might try this strategy and then I'm
saying
that strategy reflects this state of
mind this psychology rationalization
and then I'm going to say let's make the
bad situation worse let's make that
strategy not work how can we how can we
block him from his piece of watching the
video and not feeling bad
class
ah well uh maybe his supervisor calls
him
and so now he feels a little bit torn
because now sure her supervisor or
somebody says you can't do that that
that way is not allowed right or maybe
she says that's a cheap rationalization
if I ever saw one you can do it if you
want to I won't feel bad I want you to
watch the movie right but he'll say no
no I can't give her the satisfaction I
can't let her win this is something we
find over and over again when comic
filters go to war with each other the
the main motivation that every character
has is I can't let them win I have to
win that's what makes strong Comic
characters going back to Kramer
if Kramer doesn't win he's not happy and
because he has this strong comic filter
it kind of gives him super powers and he
can use the superpowers to win in
situations where you and I couldn't win
it we talk about comic filters but it's
also useful to talk about
superpowers comic superpowers because if
a character has a strong comic filter
that character will do things that you
and I can't do
that character has permission a great
example of this is uh Crossing against a
red light
normal people will cross against a red
light they won't they won't do it
they'll wait for the light to turn green
two classes of people will cross against
the red light with consistency one whose
comic filter is I don't know the rules
and another whose comic filter is the
rules don't apply to me both of those
characters will cross against the light
they will achieve a goal that normal
people can't achieve because they filter
reality through their comic filter
sure yeah I've seen a lot of that's
great because there are certain people
that are like these car Dodgers and they
just they feel it's there just right to
be it doesn't matter if it's the cars
are stopped but they feel like this is
my universe as well and I'm gonna
saunter through and you'll stop for me
it's the cliche it's a cliche of the New
Yorker I'm walking here that's from
Dustin Hoffman and Midnight Cowboy I
believe okay he's crossing the street in
New York saying I'm walking here I'm
walking here how does a writer build a
comic filter I start by looking within
and asking myself what comic filters do
I have we've already determined that I'm
playful I'm inquisitive I have curiosity
I avoid conflict
I
like to exercise
let's take that last one now I know
something that's true about myself I
like to exercise
now all I have to do is exaggerate it
what is the most extreme example of
someone who likes to exercise someone
who can't stop running no matter what
believes that all sports are great all
sporting activities are valid and
nothing else in the world is worth doing
now we have a strong comic filter made
Strong by exaggeration so how do you
make a come how do you build a comic
comic filter take normal reality and
exaggerate it until it becomes comic
reality
it's the same thing in creating a comic
premise the comic filter is the comic
premise of the character it's the way
the character differs from real reality
right now I'm thinking about the
character in about you know up shit's
creek the Eugene Levy character who just
thinks he's going to go to this small
town and everything's going to be
completely fine and cool and his comic
reality is I can cope but real reality
fights against that and his comic
reality creates the comic premise City
guy in the country
because he's driven to prove himself in
that new environment
I haven't seen the show I want to see it
so it sounds like he still has his City
sensibilities about him uh other
characters in the in the character map
have their City sensibilities as you
would imagine but let's just take a
different example let's look at Sheldon
Cooper in Big Bang Theory his comic
filter is I'm better than everyone his
superpower because he has that comic
filter is he can do things normal people
can't do he can use his arrogance to
achieve his outcomes the reality that he
lives in is Sheldon Cooper world it's
not our reality we wouldn't put up with
him but because his comic filter is so
strong it creates the comic premise that
this guy can fruitfully exist in this
world hey one last five minutes in the
real world he'd be unhappy
but in this world he can find happiness
because he has this superpower
all of which requires that we look at it
from underneath with psychological tools
and from above it with awareness and
from the audience's perspective and all
these other different angles
people think that the the idea is
developed and then it's done
a better way to think about it is when
you're pursuing a creative outcome
you're like a detective who is
simultaneously creating Clues and
following them
the more clues you create the more
effectively you can follow and the more
effectively you follow the more
discoveries you make the more
discoveries you make the more clues you
surface and the more clues you surface
the more you succeed in moving toward
your goal
should someone know their own comic
filter oh yeah is that the first as a
starting point that's starting as a
starting point what do I think is funny
and the way to think about it is this
when your friends say you're funny what
do they mean this is I'm I'm now
speaking to people who would be in my
comic toolbox Master Class they're there
because they want to be more funny than
they are so they have some they're
interested in comedy somewhere along the
way somebody told them they were funny
about something otherwise they wouldn't
be here or they thought they were funny
otherwise they wouldn't be here so what
brought them here what sensibility do
they have walking into the room that
needs to be discovered and nurtured and
expanded and exaggerated so that it
becomes a comic filter that's a platform
upon which their work can stand I've had
people say I'm clumsy people know that
I'm clumsy as an example where are you
funny I'm funny when I'm clumsy okay in
the real world you're going to try not
to be clumsy because you could get hurt
in the comic world you can be as clumsy
as you want your comic premise is I can
be clumsy and not get hurt and now
you're off and running you can take that
anywhere you want you can build a
platform for stand-up comedy routine or
you can endow that attitude on a
character in a sitcom or a comic movie
or a player comic novel it's a building
block it's not the end of the story but
it's a piece of the puzzle hence Kramer
yeah but he always lands on his feet
always lands on his feet and it's built
into the character so when we think
about comic filter we're also thinking
about something right next door called
controlling idea the comic filter is
this is how the character will be funny
because he's always clumsy but the
controlling idea is I'm not clumsy I'm
I'm elegant I'm what's the word I'm
looking for I'm
drawn a blank synonym not ambidextrous
Siri give me some synonyms for clumsy
for Deft uh anyway you get the idea his
his
controlling idea is I'm going to prove
to the world how cool and smooth I am
his comic filter is I'm clumsy and those
two things fight against each other in
an interesting way
and that's what makes the character
interesting when his comic filter is one
thing and his controlling idea fights
against it you have automatic inner
conflict
Jack Tripper Three's Company yep what a
great thank you I was trying to think of
an example Jack Tripper whose comic
filter is women love me right and who's
no who's who's and his control I get
this I guess I have this wrong his comic
filter is I'm no good with women but his
controlling idea is I'm great with women